hello and welcome to this video playing
FM mata leão with black wow the wing
gambit the wing gambit after e6 ok so
the d5 would be a French a kind of
French I know that this is good for
black this line but i don't really know
the details these that's what friends
told me who play the French that this is
good for black but well I'm very far
away from being an expert I think they
told me not to castle which is kind of
making some sense but it's still a
French which I don't like
okay so i can take actually and yeah
Castle castle short might be five mm-hmm
ok let's prevent this for the moment h5
h6 I don't think I'd like to see that
happening mm okay so cringy for is
probably coming up I have to cancel here
I think
yeah i was thinking is night f5 good
let's do that that that blocks the whole
staff for at least for a moment get a
temp on c3 here which she does not
really appreciate okay let's get rid of
that get rid of that bishop here I
really have experienced so many
problematic games with that dreaded
bishop so I'm happy to get rid of it
yeah it's it's an issue here you're
taking is not good this anyplace going
to be six probably
hmm
for good c7 it's not quite clear what my
next move is
okay don't don't see something really
really good oh wow didn't see that at
all okay check
I really hate the French defense
whatever you do a you can you put a camp
blunder like two pawns yeah and you're
still sitting against those bloody e5
pawn and you have no space and
everything but I really really hate it
not even this is a clear win yeah not
even this is a clear win queen bee three
maybe it's still firmly a draw it takes
in seven but my night I cannot move this
night
96 20 x is also not good I'll check
actually I wanted to live in I don't
know check now you can take f7 at the
end should have just make make it to me
to draw them somehow and yeah you can
now go for perpetual
yeah night at five we have to make a
give a perpetual we can do that himself
now I am ok with the draw I just hated
this position your time morning still
sitting there and it's just jack it's no
fun I just wonder is there more looks a
little bit strange check check don't see
more check
check are you threatening me to himself
so check it's just a draw draw autocheck
game drive is thought to do sir yeah
check no here you cannot win anymore
just just too passive there's this whole
all kind of set up after rupee 7 it's
already a draw even this position here
I'm not two pawns up here and you're
still struggling to to win this because
of the bloody space disadvantage yeah I
know I should win this game somehow it
may be here really prevent 26 or
something I didn't see Ruby said that
was good move of course check tik no I
shall win this is also just to draw
check check check yeah it's never easy
to play this it's just no no space and
it's it's awkward just awkward to play
in tier I don't know if he covers c3 I
mean you just blonde at this porn 1c3 I
mean that's no sacrifice you just
blended it I think ya de Steve blunder
drooped XD 3 but it's still not winning
well this is this is really crazy i
probably have to do this to prevent him
from playing 3d6 in the first place but
then we'll be six and i don't know why
it is still continuing this this game
it's I don't like it even the best
possible version of the French would
like ok guys thanks for watching